bonjour vous avez une chaîne youtube et
vous voulez gagner de l'argent avec
vous rêvez même de devenir youtuber à
temps complet il existe cinq moyens
principaux de gagner de l'argent sur
youtube
il y en a certains qui marche très bien
et on a d'autres qui ne marche pas du
tout on va regarder ça ensemble
de plus en plus de chaînes ne voit le
jour sur youtube il est extrêmement
difficile de réussir je partage avec
vous toutes les astuces et mes
meilleures techniques pour gagner des
vues les convertir en abonnés et enfin
réussir sur youtube inscrivez vous au
mas chaîne est activé la cloche pour ne
manquer aucune vidéo
si vous voulez aller plus loin sur
youtube cliquez sur le lien pour
rejoindre la communauté question de
jours comment est ce que vous faites
vous aujourd'hui pour gagner de l'argent
sur youtube d'ailleurs est ce que vous
gagnez de l'argent sur youtube est-ce
que vous avez des astuces un peu
particulière comment est-ce que vous
procédez mais tu es maintenant
commentaire je suis impatient de pouvoir
en discuter avec vous vous passer du
temps sur youtube vous adorez faire des
vidéos et franchement c'est génial et
vous avez raison d'ailleurs c'est pareil
pour moi aussi le problème sur youtube
par contre c'est de gagner de l'argent
dès lors que vous pouvez gagner de
l'argent peut vous dégager du temps pour
passer plus de temps à faire vos vidéos
améliorer votre contenu car de plus en
plus de qualité
achetez du meilleur matériel est
vraiment vous professionnaliser sauf que
ça paraît pas tout de suite très très
évident de savoir quelle est la bonne
méthode pour une et l'argent sur youtube
il ya cinq points essentiels pour une et
sa vie sur youtube le tout premier c'est
adsense la publicité sur youtube
publicité que vous allez avoir au début
de votre vidéo lors du chargement ou par
exemple sinon les bannières que vous
allez retrouver directement sur votre
vidéo à 100 c'est quand même la façon de
gagner d'argent sur youtube la moins
rémunératrice à moins de faire des
millions de vues d'avoir des vidéos qui
cartonne et de faire des millions des
millions et des millions de vue sinon
vous allez globalement gagner peu de
chose avec ça vous permettra peut-être
au bout de quelques mois de pouvoir
investir dans du matériel peu coûteuse
mais sinon vous n'allez pas aller très
très loin il existe un autre système qui
est beaucoup plus intéressant et qui
peut être rémunérateur en fonction de
votre niche c'est la filiation il existe
des plateformes d'affiliation vous allez
avoir de la filiation très généraliste
comme sur amazon ou à pouvoir trouver un
catalogue énorme avec un petit peuple un
produit à pro
posez vous pouvez en avoir sur des sites
high tech pour n'avoir sur la fnac sur
darty ya plein de plateformes sur du
prêt-à-porter il existe plein de
solutions pour pouvoir faire de la
filiation le principe est simple vous
insérez un lien dans votre description
mais il surfe automobile le dire dans
votre vidéo d'aller consulter le lien
vous insérez un lien dès lors que
quelqu'un cliquer dessus et achète par
le biais de ce lien vous est
commissionné la filiation peu varié dans
faible pourcentage un plus gros
pourcentage en fonction de la campagne
fonction des produits vous allez
proposer celui qui a probablement
aujourd'hui plus de succès sur youtube
c'est amazon avec son catalogue qui est
extrêmement large de soi rémunératoire
vous vraiment que vous soyez dans une
niche si vous êtes trop généraliste
globalement ça ne va pas
particulièrement marché aux choux des
vidéos sur des produits influencée
notamment sur des différents smartphones
prononça pour exemple lorsque je parle
du smartphone et que le produit est déjà
en vente
je vous invite à cliquer dans le lire
dans la description pour aller voir le
produit et ses qualifications ne vais
pas me donner de l'argent pour pouvoir
continuer à travailler sur youtube un
autre système qui est très intéressant
c'est de travailler avec des marques
aujourd'hui à des plateformes qui met en
relation les influenceurs et les marques
les marques sont vraiment demande
d'avoir des relais auprès des
influenceurs et vous allez pouvoir s'y
trouvaient des campagnes sur lequel vous
allez être rémunéré au clic vous allez
être rémunéré au nom de vue vous allez
très modérée différentes manières ça
peut être un bon moyen de gagner votre
vie dès lors que vous proposez une
marque qui correspond à votre niche et
qui va intéresser votre audience si
c'est faire une vidéo pour faire une
vidéo globalement ça n'a pas d'intérêt
mais d'ailleurs vous avez une niche qui
est vraiment défini et que sur ses
plates formes de mise en relation vous
allez trouver des marques qui
correspondent à votre audience là vous
allez voir c'est très intéressant
attention il ne faut surtout pas trompé
son audience ce n'est pas parce que vous
parlez d'une marque ou que vous parlez
d'un produit pour lequel vous êtes
rémunéré au clic qu'il faut pas être
objectif restait toujours objectifs
sinon votre audience le saura à ce
moment là ils vont des abonnés et vos
avis vos conseils ne vaudront plus rien
à notre moyen qui est très intéressant
qui se développe de plus en plus
notamment aujourd'hui pour les créateurs
de contenu de divertissement pour des
gens qui vont réaliser des
courts-métrages c'est le revenu sur tipi
ce sont les tips des personnes vous
soutiennent elle vous envoie de l'argent
mensuellement ou par contenu et vous
vous le collectés alors il faut une
contrepartie s'appelle du contenu
exclusif
ça peut être des choses à télécharger ou
carrément des choses à renvoyer donc ça
c'est des choses qui se développe
énormément c'est très intéressant
en france on atypique qui marche très
très bien et qui est un super moyen de
fédérer une communauté
on a par exemple sorti piger fédérer une
communauté de créateurs qui veulent
avoir vraiment des informations pour
développer leur chaîne youtube et qui
veulent aller beaucoup plus loin pour
mettre en place les bonnes stratégies
c'est à dire je vous invite à cliquer
dans description si vous voulez me
rejoindre sur tipi pour avoir toujours
les bonnes astuces et les bonnes
méthodes pour réussir sur youtube et
pour aller plus loin dans votre projet
et vous verrez qu'ils puissent est très
intéressant c'est gagnant gagnant
il faut que ce soit gagnant pour le
créateur effectivement ça nous rapporte
une source de revenus supplémentaires
il faut que ce soit vraiment gagnant
pour la personne qui va mettre de
l'argent par exemple dans mon cas vous
donne des astuces des conseils sur tâche
avec vous du contenu exclusif qu'on ne
trouve pas sur youtube il ya un
accompagnement je vais répondre à vos
questions vous serez prioritaire dans
les faq je vous faire des vidéos
exclusives et puis on va prendre le
temps prend le temps de regarder quelles
sont vos problématiques et comment on
peut les résoudre
pour vous puissiez progresser sur
youtube est le dernier point à mon avis
qui est plus intéressant c'est vous si
votre valeur ajoutée
si vous avez une expertise dans un
domaine particulier et que vous apporter
des conseils
le mieux encore c'est de le monétiser
bien évidemment vous devez en parler sur
dur des vidéos gratuits sur votre chaîne
youtube c'est d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt
mais pour approfondir pour aller plus
loin vous pouvez proposer des formations
proposées des ebooks des vidéos
exclusives que vous allez pouvoir après
monétiser directement auprès de votre
audience dès lors que vous avez une
expertise dès lors que vous avez des
conseils apportés
c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée et ça
vous pouvez le monétiser vous saurez
profiter votre audience et ça vous
permettre à vous de continuer à
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
dans tous ces domaines dans toutes ces
façons de monétiser le point essentiel
savoir avant tout qu est ce que vous
vous apporter quel est votre valeur quel
est votre valeur ajoutée pourquoi est ce
qu'un utilisateur de youtube a intérêt à
venir vous voir qu'est ce qu'il va
trouver en quoi est ce que votre
expertise est intéressante et pourquoi
est ce qu'on devrait faire appel à vos
conseils que ce soit sur travaille avec
des marques que ce soit en vente directe
sur dix huit bouts que ce soit sur du
soutien son tipi que ce soit son de
l'affiliation sur un lien d'affiliation
pourquoi est-ce qu'on irait regarder
votre vidéo et pourquoi on irrigue clics
et sans marché de l'affiliation plutôt
que sur un autre
qu'est ce que vous apportez en plus
posez vous cette question est dès lors
vous avez la réponse vous allez voir
tout va s'ouvrir et vous allez pouvoir
monétiser
gagner de l'argent et travailler sur
youtube à temps complet merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser des commentaires je me
ferais un grand plaisir d'y répondre
abonnez-vous aux machines parce qu'il
aura toujours plus de contenu pour vous
aider à réussir sur youtube
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
et d'ici là portez vous bien ça lui
[Musique]